الى العواجل في مطار صغيبول الذي نشاهد
الان هذه الصور المباشره التي تاتينا من
هناك من امستردام نشاطاء بيئه يقتحمون هذا
المطار
ويقومون بتعطيل حركه الطيران طبعا هناك
عمليه خاصه في الدول الاوروبيه الناشطه في
ما يتعلق بارسال رسائل حول البيئه واهميه
المحافظه عليها والتغير المناخي الذي كان
له اهداف ولكن همم هناك تاخر في الالتزام
بذلك تراجع من بعض الدول وخاصه في حرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه وبعد ان كان الحديث
كله يتوجه الى البدائل من اجل الحفاظ على
البيئه بدائل الطاقه تحول الحديث للعوده
الى استخدام الفحم وذلك في ظل الازمه
المتعلقه بالطاقه والتي طبعا
تصاعدت في الفتره الاخيره ما بين الموقف
الروسي ما بين الامدادات الموجوده
واستهدافات ايضا
لنور ستريم واحد اضافه الى العقوبات التي
فرضت على روسيا والعقوبات الفرضت على
العمله الروسيه وطبعا اخر المواقف تلك
المتعلقه بتسقيف سعر الطاقه اذا هناك
تحركات نشطه همم مؤخرا وظاهره بسبب تداول
الصور على وسائل الاعلام طبعا
باحد المتاحف كان هناك همم استهداف لوحه
من اللوحات الفنيه المعروفه من قبل
الناشطين همم ايضا هناك حراك في اكثر من
مكان واخره كما نشاهد من خلال هذه الصور
المباشره نشطاء بيئه يقتحمون هذا المطار
في امستردام وهو مطار اسقيبول كما انه
نشاهد على العواجل ويقومون بتعطيل الحركه